et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
marie bigard humoriste bonsoir jean
marie bigard merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france allant à vous ne
cautionnez pas vous les propos de jérôme
rodriguez et vous n'irez pas à la
manifestation de samedi vous avez
préféré apparemment allée à brett c'est
ça oui je joue à brest et j'en rencontre
rennes et si les jeunes que je verrai
sur place pour dire ma solidarité avec
les plus démunis et les gens qui
travaillent et qui payent leurs impôts
et qui on chie 5 du mois
faut pas dire du 2 ça veut dire quoi
concrètement vous seriez allé à paris
mais vous n'avez peut-être pas envie
d'être associé avec des propos vous vous
jugez peut-être un peu trop extrême un
départ de jérôme aurait gelé
c'est pire que ça je vais je condamne
absolument
moi je suis un ami de la police la
police en ce moment et depuis beaucoup
de moi est entre le marteau et l'enclume
et et ils sont là et je connais beaucoup
défendre si tu veux les lois de la
république peut pas alors taper dessus
ce n'est pas possible 7 cette phrase
qu'il a prononcée est inouï qu elle est
condamnable c'est à dire on peut pas
dire que les flics français sont des
nazis même si c'est vrai si ça s'adresse
à un seul ou un peu flic c'est comme si
on condamnait la police française si tu
veux tout entière donc je ne peux pas
m'afficher avec quelqu'un dont je ne
partage pas les idées tout simplement
c'est la raison pour laquelle j rey
comme je le fais quotidiennement et
pendant toute ma tournée
j'ai un comité de gilet jaune qui
m'attendent à l'entrée de chaque salle
où je joue en france
et je les invite par 10 15 30 ou 40 pour
le jeu des chaises et je les invite à
michael parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'argent
pour venir rigolé pendant deux heures
jean marie bigard juste pour terminer
sur ce chapitre guéguerre police une
partie des gilets jaunes dont surtout
jérôme rodriguez effectivement vous
l'avez toujours dit je suis un ami de la
police aussi bien que je suis un ami
mais gilet jaune est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui une forme de
pression médiatique peu importe qui
pousse finalement être obligé de choisir
un camp ben bien sûr bien sûr d'ailleurs
nos gouvernants connaissent par exemple
la la le cancer de toutes les
manifestations
ce sont les casseurs c'est ce qui énerve
seulement tout tout le monde les connaît
par leur nom et leur prénom avec des
centaines et centaines de caméras mais
le nos gouvernants décide de les
utiliser par exemple quand qu'ils ont
décidé de ne pas faire ce qu'il faisait
d'habitude pour protéger les champs
elysées ou laisser les casseurs massacre
est la plus belle avenue du monde en se
disant avec ça on va tuer les gilets
jaunes mais va pas tuer
on ne tue pas la multitude et ya une
multitude de gens qui sont mécontents en
colère qui paient sans sourcilier leurs
impôts qui travaillent et qui n'arrivent
pas à joindre les deux bouts et cela je
suis avec eux et je le montrerai que
j'arriverai à brest pour jouer à
guipavas samedi et bien je tomberai
forcément sur un comité de gilet jaune
que je salue et tu vas y
comme je le fais tous les jours
je faisais avant le confinement pour
qu'ils puissent assister à mon sweat
alors effectivement sa rentrée ce samedi
en tout cas marque le retour des
manifestations de gilet jaune
j'ai eu cette période de confinement
comment justement vous percevez l'avenir
est ce que entre guillemets pour vous
les choses empirent ce mouvement va
s'amplifier marqué le pas restée égale
quel est votre sentiment
je pense que ce qui va nous arriver va
être terrible si elle veut dire la
colère qu'on n'a pas écouté du peuple va
revenir à nos gouvernants comme un
élastique et ça va être très très fort
nos gouvernants ne savent pas que on n'a
pas le droit de mépriser le peuple à ce
point et je pense qu'ils vont le
comprendre dans les mois qui viennent
alors beaucoup d'arrêter un préfectoraux
vous le savez ont été pris pour
interdire la manifestation dans certains
secteurs dans de nombreuses rues à paris
on n'oublie pas qu'on est en pleine
crise sanitaire
est ce qu'on doit s'entendre s'attendre
vous le craignez en tout cas un face à
face avec la police
c'est vraisemblable puisque cote quand
on refuse d'ouvrir la porte
évidemment tu es un peu tendance à la
défoncer la la violence et est lié
intimement avec toutes les
manifestations populaires
c'est impossible autrement donc il est
vraisemblable que on s'achemine vers
beaucoup de rancoeur et beaucoup de
gérance de parts et d'autres
alors vous vous défendez vous
effectivement les revendications
premières un déjeuner
plus de justice plus d'égalité de
démocratie pouvoir d'achat il ya quand
même eu quelques appels sur facebook en
dénonçant de jeu de la part de gilet
jaune en dénonçant une dictature
sanitaires et celle de l'obligation du
port du masque qui se sont rajoutés à
ses revendications habituelles est-ce
que vous cautionnez ça écoutez on vit on
a masqué 7 milliards de personnes sur la
planète alors que nous avons aujourd'hui
je parle pas de mars dernier nous avons
aujourd'hui un virus qui un peu moribond
qui se soigne très bien nous avons deux
traitements par deux médecins français
cocorico
tu vois qu'ils soient ni n'importe
quelle personne en quelques jours et on
condamne la terre entière à porter un
masque et c'est absolument scandaleux et
je ne sais pas quand je vous parle à qui
profite le crime
ce que je sais c'est que c'est
insupportable de savoir que des médecins
comme le professeur out ou comme sabine
palières franco tous les deux avec deux
procédés d'ailleurs un petit peu
différent soigne à 100% les gens et que
on continue à nous obliger à obliger 7
milliards de personnes à bord et un
masque c'est une une choses incohérentes
et je la dénonce aujourd'hui devant vous
je me garde
je tiens à préciser parce que sinon je
serais pas dans mon rôle qu
effectivement c'est votre avis est votre
opinion
les chiffres sont inquiétants concernant
le coronavirus certains voilà bons coups
en tout cas a dit ce qu'il pense et le
traitement valable et évidemment les
autorités soutiennent encore du masque
et voilà l'obligation de porter le
masque
cela et délits les gardiens que
l'entrevue engouement qui dit fois un
coup dans un sens un coup dans l'autre
on nous a dit le masque c'est entre eux
après on nous a dit il est obligatoire
qu'est ce que les français peuvent
penser de ça une chose est sûre c'est
que les gentils sont soignés avec les
deux traitements que je viens de citer à
81,19 forçant évite le buteur et le mort
est donc assez votre avis merci jean
marie bigard d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et de nous avoir à
exprimer votre opinion